Rhianna now your you use your accent in  the film and and but I didn't realize  that your axe that was kind of the  reason why you had your first big hit  that's how you got umbrella because lots  of people wanted that song a lot of  people message all week I've pretty I've  got to ask you any chance of a new album  or anything or have you just walked away  from that who sent you I know one of my  fans got to you Graham no no they  honestly stopped my twitter feed has  just been full of can you use I actually  am in the studio and working on new  music  I mean is there a deadline it's really  given it so much it paid you well be out  in time for Christmas you just have to  wait and see okay I'll come back when I  put it out  that'll be back I do it are you  you're gonna throw me an idea we didn't  do a song together like the video  [Applause]  oh yeah  [Music]